je tiens à remercier le président xavier
pichon zik d'avoir bien voulu se
présenter devant notre commission
quelques heures quelques heures
seulement après que rte a rendu public
son analyse saisonnière du passage de
l'hiver 2022 2023 dans le cadre de ses
missions légales rte établit en effet
périodiquement des analyses
prévisionnelles sur l' équilibre entre
l'offre et la demande d'électricité en
france en cette rentrée 2022 ces années
ils sont particulièrement attendues du
fait des incertitudes liées à la
continuité des approvisionnements en gaz
et à la disponibilité effective du parc
nucléaire incertitude accrue par les
tensions inédite pesant sur le système
électrique européen interconnectés notre
commission a entendu hier la ministre
agnès pannier runes haché et ce matin
jean bernard lévy le pdg d'edf nous
avons longuement évoquée à ces deux
occasions les causes des difficultés que
nous allons devoir affronter la présente
auditions devraient plutôt nous donner
l'occasion de discuter des divers
scénarios qui sont envisageables j'ai
d'ailleurs cru pouvoir noter à la suite
de votre conférence de presse dans la
matinée que vous n'aviez pas forcément
le même optimisme qu edf sur la remise
en production avant la fin janvier de
l'ensemble des 32 réacteurs actuellement
à l'arrêt vous allez évidemment nous
expliquer les raisons qui motivent cette
prudence potentiel dans vos explications
nous allons nous pencher essentiellement
lors de la présente auditions sur le
court terme mais je voudrais aussi
rappeler que rte a finalisé en février
dernier un rapport très important sur
les futurs énergétique à l'horizon de
2050 et vous étiez d'ailleurs venu le 27
octobre 2021 monsieur le président pour
présenter à la commission la première
mouture de ce rapport et je souhaiterais
rappeler plusieurs constatations
principal de cette étude la première
c'est que la consommation d'énergie
devraient baisser globalement mais celle
d'électricité va augmenter pour se
substituer aux énergies fossiles et on
l'espère accompagner la
réindustrialisation du pays
le deuxième élément c'est que le
développement des énergies renouvelables
est nécessaire pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone et le troisième
élément c'est que la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires et
pertinente du point de vue économique
sans passer impliquerez en outre des
rythmes de croissance des énergies
renouvelables plus rapides que ceux
constatés dans les pays européens les
plus dynamiques je vous laisse désormais
nous faire part de vos analyses pour cet
hiver mais j'aimerais aussi que vous
nous indiquer si la crise actuelle remet
en cause vos constatations sur le long
terme
je précise que vous m'avez demandé
l'autorisation de pouvoir dépasser la
durée habituelle imparti aux
intervention liminaire salut d'habitude
c'est une vingtaine de minutes 15
minutes afin de disposer d'environ 40
minutes de temps de parole nous en avons
discuté en bureau nous avons convenu que
c'était totalement acceptée vous aviez
une présentation à nous montrer et donc
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer pendant
ses trente cinq minutes monsieur le
président est ensuite même principe que
d'habitude les orateurs groupe les
questions individuelles sachant que nous
avons jusqu'à 17 heures pile puisque
nous recevons dans la foulée bruno le
maire donc monsieur le président vous
avez maintenant la parole merci encore
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires merci nous
accueillir
voici avec thomas vérins qui est avec
moi qui est directeur exécutif en charge
de la stratégie de la prospective et de
l'évaluation au sein de rte de vous
résumer ce que nous avons dit ce matin
en conférence de presse donc
pardonnez-nous à l'avance d'être parfois
trop rapide et laconique mais on va
essayer de laisser du temps pour les
questions alors sans transition je vais
vous présenter ce que nous avons dit ce
matin et vous résumer en substance les
enseignements de nos études nous savons
que nous connaissons en ce moment une
situation exceptionnelle à trois égards
eu une crise gazière qui est européenne
une crise de la production du nucléaire
qui allait bien française mais aussi une
sécheresse historique qui influent sur
les stocks hydrauliques et qui nous
conduisent à faire attention à ce type
de production
alors ça s'inscrit historiquement dans
un contexte où la france a fermé ces dix
dernières années beaucoup de moyens
thermiques pour des raisons climatiques
le fioul par exemple qui produisait de
l'électricité
quelques centrales à charbon aussi et
l'ensemble des nouveaux moyens de
production qui était supposée s'y
substituer dans le cadre d'une
consommation à peu près constante je
parle des énergies renouvelables et je
parle de le p r de flamanville sont en
retard
alors pour faire face à cette situation
exceptionnelle
de contraintes de marge sur le système
électrique nous avons adapté le
dispositif de présentation
du passage de l'hiver et il ya un
certain nombre de paramètres qui change
par rapport à l'an dernier le premier
paramètre c'est que c'est une des
premières fois que la période de risque
du passage de l'hiver elle n'est pas
concentrée autour du mois de janvier
mais elle va commencer dès la mi octobre
probablement donc en fait quand je vais
vous dire hiver il faut entendre six
mois d'octobre à mars
d'autre part le bon déroulé de cet hiver
il reposera sur des actions de sobriété
alors c'est notamment le plan que
prépare le gouvernement et auquel nous
avons contribué mais aussi sur des
nouveaux sur des outils nouveaux comme
le dispositif ecowatt qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à rodez le plus vite possible j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure
et en troisième le on constate que nous
faisons en ce moment tout ce
que que nous constatons pardon tous en
ce moment une forme d' emballement des
prix de l'électricité sur les marchés à
terme
prix qui sont marques qui sont passé
brutalement d'un univers où la situation
de risque n'était pas prise en compte du
tout à un univers où seul le scénario du
pire forme le prix c'est la raison pour
laquelle on vous expliquera pourquoi
selon nous
les prix à terme de l'électricité au
début de l'année 2000 23
atteignent aujourd'hui des sommets et
met en danger un certain d'entreprise je
veux redire ici mais je leur dirai plus
tard nous considérons que le scénario du
pire derrière lequel à travers lequel se
forment les prix de marché à terme en ce
moment est très improbable
et il était nécessaire à travers notre
expression ce matin est devant vous que
nous lui que nous communiquions les
éléments qui permettront aux acteurs
économiques de se faire une idée précise
et quantifier de la situation de l'hiver
afin que les acteurs économiques
prennent leurs arbitrages en
connaissance de cause thomas vers
inquiète à côté de moi en parlera à la
suite de mon propos est bien évidemment
nous répondrons à quelques questions si
vous enlevez sur le sujet
alors j'ai peut-être faire quelques
discrets mais maintenant nous avons
conduites cette étude selon la méthode
classique de rte
la première c'est que
nous avons fait une
une vaste concertation flash à l'été
avec l'ensemble des parties prenantes du
secteur énergétique pour recueillir les
hypothèses les plus à jour sur l'état du
parc de production
deuxième élément de méthode nous avons
analysé le système le système électrique
systèmes énergétiques à l'échelle
européenne notre modèle court toute
l'europe
il est il écrit la production et la
consommation d'électricité dans
l'ensemble des pays d'europe et nous
verrons sion l'ensemble de nos
hypothèses avec nos voisins européens
avec nos homologues gestionnaires de
réseaux de transport avec qui nous
travaillons quotidiennement
cette année nous avons veillé enfin
avoir une coordination étroite avec les
études de grt gaz car un grand nombre de
questions sont connexes ce qui fait de
nous que nos deux analyse celle que j'ai
regaz a notamment présenté cet après
midi en conférence de presse ont
parfaitement coordonnés
et enfin nous avons analysé un très
grand nombre de situations
de configuration technique sur le
nucléaire sur la consommation sur les
échanges d'électricité et des situations
surtout météorologiques différentes de
sorte à ce qu ont disposé ce qu'on
présente devant vous des résultats
probabiliste donc probabilité ce dont je
vais parler ce sont des probabilités qui
donne une bonne vision de ce à quoi on
peut être confronté tous ensemble cet
hiver
en méthode lorsqu'on travaille comme ça
on commence par étudier à sa tombe re de
paramètres et de les discuter pour les
présenter en transparence nous avons
donc discuté chaque grand un paramètre
de l'équilibré offre demande du système
électrique toujours avec une hypothèse
centrale est toujours avec des variantes
alors ces grands paramètres sont les
suivants voulait deviner le niveau de
consommation d'électricité avec une
hypothèse centre à une variante battu
une variante haute la production
nucléaire sur laquelle sur le plan je ne
doute pas que nous aurons des questions
la production hydraulique la production
de renouvelables
les centrales à gaz la production des
centrales à charbon en france et en
europe les effacements de consommation
et enfin les échanges d'électricité
tous ces éléments de méthode et si vous
voulez les uns et des autres pouvoir
disposer de l'ensemble des éléments
discutés de tous ces paramètres entrant
de notre étude sont disponibles dans la
publication que nous avons fait ce matin
qui est en ligne sur notre site internet
est bien évidemment c'est disponible
pour tous
alors je vais essayer maintenant
d'entrer dans le coeur de nos résultats
pour cet hiver on a défini trois grands
types de scénarios d'un provisionnement
qui dépendent essentiellement de la
production et les importations
on a construit un scénario central
vous verrez dans les slides il s'appelle
intermédiaires ou centrale mais c'est un
scénario central et deux variantes une
basse de production dégradés dont qui
s'appelle le scénario dégradé et une
autre qui s'appelle scénario haut donc
nous avons un scénario central un
scénario aux de production et un ca na
loba qui s'appelle le scénario dégradé
et je vais commencer devant vous par le
plus difficile c'est à dire le scénario
dégradé et vous parlez des hypothèses
qu'on a prises pour faire notre étude
dans ce scénario on a considéré que la
consommation était flat c'est à dire
qu'elle était durant l'hiver comme
aujourd'hui à 1 ou 2% en dessous des
consommations de la france d'avant
locaux vides on prend jamais les
références de consommation d'électricité
pendant le coc vide parce que vous savez
que la vie a été particulièrement
perturbé la bonne référence c'est la
dernière année avant le coc vie
d'aujourd'hui la france consomme 1 ou 2%
en dessous de ce qu'elle commises de de
ce qu'elle consomme est ce juste avant
le coc vide
et dans ce scénario qu'on appelle
dégrader
ce qui est important de retenir c'est
qu'on s'est mis dans l'hypothèse où les
tensions sur le gaz en europe sont très
importantes et se traduirait par les
pénuries qui toucherait la production
d'électricité normale à travers les
centrales à gaz en france et en europe
pour nous ce scénario dégradé c'est bien
ça c'est l'impact de la crise gazière
sur les centrales à gaz qui se trouve en
france et en europe pourquoi c'est
important de se poser cette question
parce que si d'aventuré un tel scénario
devait arriver ça a un impact sur les
importations d'électricité vers la
france et cet hiver nous allons avoir
besoin de beaucoup d'importation donc
c'était normal conteste un scénario
c'est un peu un crash test de scénarios
gazier dégradé à travers la le
fonctionnement normal
des centrales à gaz alors c'est c'est un
monde dans lequel les arrêts entre pays
ne s'arrêterait pas mais
les centrales à gaz ne fonctionneraient
pas comme elles fonctionnent normalement
dans un marché libre et donc la france
ne pourrait pas compter sur tous les
imports dont dont elle a besoin
j'ajoute qu'un scénario dégradé de ce
type là
peut aussi s'envisager dans l'hypothèse
où le parc nucléaire tarderait vraiment
revenir sur réseau mais là on serait
dans des perspectives de retard
absolument majeur de maintenance pour ce
serait du point de vue du parc nucléaire
un scénario particulièrement dégradé
voilà les hypothèses de ce que je vais
appeler scénario dégradé c'est important
que je vous explique ça parce qu'après
vous allez voir une slide qui va décrire
ces différents scénarios et les
différentes probabilité de de tension
sur le système électrique que ça peut
générer
alors maintenant je vais vous dire un
mot de notre scénario central
c'est le principal scénario dans ce
scénario la consommation poursuit la
tendance actuelle c'est à dire de
l'ordre de -1 à -2 % par rapport à
l'année d'avant qu'ovide ce qui veut
dire que le plan sobriété dont on parle
n'aurait eu dans cette hypothèse que des
effets qui seraient encore modeste en
tout cas pour le début de l'hiver
nous avons pris dans cette hypothèse
centrale
une disponibilité du parc nucléaire qui
remonte progressivement d'ici janvier
mais nous avons retenu une vision
prudente de cette disponibilité de parc
nucléaire
de l'ordre de 38 gigawatts au 1er
décembre est de 45 gigawatt au 1er
janvier
c'est clair sur les chiffres parce que
je sais qu'il ya des questions autour de
7,2 cette trajectoire alors c'est une
trajectoire qu'on publie en transparence
on explique comment est ce qu'on l'a
construite et bien évidemment elle est
challenger et on y reviendra tout à
l'heure lorsque thomas verhaeghe prendra
la parole
sur les prix
dans scénario normal pour nous dans le
ce dans ce scénario principal
il n'y a pas d'impact de la crise
gazière sur le fonctionnement des
centrales à gaz
du coup nous considérons dans ce
scénario central que les échanges
d'électricité entre les pays répondent
aux lois de l'offre et à la demande sans
entraves particulière comme ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui
alors ce scénario central ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que c'est un scénario
qu'on considère comme prudent et on l'a
fait on l'a fait pour cela j'ai un bruit
monsieur le président c'est moi qui suis
trop près du micro
c'est un scénario intermédiaire c'est un
scénario central mais nous l'avons
construit comme un scénario prudent
prudent notamment donc en matière d
actions de sobriété je vous ai dit que
on avait considéré que un éventuel plan
n'aurait pas eu beaucoup d'effet et on
l'a fait exprès du point de vue
méthodologique
je je je vous en parlerai plus tard
et c'est aussi un scénario prudent sur
la disponibilité du parc nucléaire aux
deux jalons qu'on a repéré disponibilité
du parc nucléaire au 1er décembre
disponibilité du parc au 1er janvier
voilà pour notre scénario central pour
notre hypothèse centrale qu'on a pris un
scénario
sur lequel on joue essentiellement sur
le productible nucléaire et là nous
avons considéré que
le parc nucléaire serait davantage
disponibles et que la france disposerait
de 40 gigawatts de nucléaire au 1er
décembre et de 50 au 1er janvier
alors ses jalons et ses volumes de
puissance il ne s'y serait une parfaite
maîtrise des arts est en cours et est à
venir et à la remise en service pendant
l'hiver de plusieurs réacteurs qui sont
affectés par la corrosion sous
contrainte et donc j'imagine vous avez
parlé avec edf ce matin ce scénario il
est accessible au moment où on se parle
mais vu de nous c'est notre meilleur
c'est notre estimation excusez moi c'est
notre estimation de la mer disposent de
la meilleure disponibilité qui est
encore possible
c'est une forme de maximum mais il ne
faut plus qui est d'aller à entre
maintenant et le début de l'hiver
est comme ça constitue à nos yeux une
forme le maximum c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons papier ce scénario
non
dans notre hypothèse centrale qu'il y a
quand même intégré un certain nombre de
prudence et quelques retards
alors ce scénario en matière de
production nucléaire il les
volontaristes
on pourrait tout à fait concevoir qu'il
soit aussi volontariste pour ce qui
concerne la sobriété parce que je
voulais dire on avait pris en entrée des
hypothèses de consommation dans
lesquelles
les frais du plan sobriété n'aurait eu
que des des conséquences modeste en
toute hypothèse ce scénario volontariste
il nécessite des bougé par rapport aux
tendances que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors on va vous montrer la synthèse de
nos résultats le juste avant vous dire
que dans le tableau que vous allez voir
et qu'on peut projeter maintenant
précisions techniques monsieur le
président nous avons un petit souci
technique avec la projection puisque les
cliques cheikh sarr est bloquée at on
affaire presser un câble hdmi ça devrait
s'afficher bientôt ok alors le service
informatique de l'assemblée se déplace
est ce que monsieur le président vous
voulez que je ralentisse non on va
rentrer dans un moment où je pense que
c'est important qu'on ait un tableau
sous les yeux allez c'est important oui
mais je j'entends bien
néanmoins l'écran est bloqué à ce
stade-là donc alors dont
alors vous avez suivi et sans cela
jusqu'à présent parce que oui jusqu'à
présent on suivait bien c'était
difficile bon mais est-ce que c'était
compréhensible bon merci et merci
attendait parce que j'ai compris km est
ce qu'on peut se dépêcher de mettre le
gala est ce que je vous propose si vous
êtes d'accord je veux bien faire une
suspension mais deux trois minutes
histoire que la rapidement au met en
place le câble on puisse projeter et
qu'on reprend dans trois minutes ça vous
va on suspend trois minutes on règle le
problème technique et on reprend merci
donc le programme le problème technique
est réglée chers collègues vous pouvez
voir sur le tableau derrière nous toutes
les données qui sont évoqués par
monsieur le président j'ai par exemple à
nouveau la parole merci monsieur le
président alors du coup on ne va pas
vous repasser en hyper accélérer
l'ensemble des slides qui aurait dû
accompagner mon propos introductif
mais monsieur le président nous mettrons
à votre disposition le slide show si les
parlementaires veulent en bénéficier
in extenso sans aucune difficulté alors
ce tableau synthétise nos résultats il
faut que je vous explique un peu à les
unités qu'on a utilisé et vous allez
voir que dans ce tableau on parle des
mesures de sauvegarde alors qu'est ce
qu'une mesure de sauvegarde mesures de
sauvegarde du système électrique c'est
laisser les procédures qui sont à la
main du gestionnaire de réseau de
transport donc à la main notre
entreprise
et elles sont activés lorsque le
fonctionnement du seul marché n'a pas
résolu le problème de l'équilibré
offre/demande parfait
tous les jours de l'année la plupart du
temps c'est le marché qui équilibrent
l'offre demande par des mécanismes assez
complexes sur lesquels si vous êtes
intéressés on pourra revenir dessus mais
quand on est en manque d'énergie en fait
ça ne suffit pas toujours et après il ya
des mesures de sauvegarde qui existe en
fait il en existe quatre qu'on appelle
successivement pour garantir l'équilibré
offre demande à chaque seconde la
consommation doit être est égale à la
production
première mesure de sauvegarde c'est la
mise en oeuvre du signal ecobat rouge ça
c'est une mesure de sauvegarde nous
mêmes nouvelles qu'on a développé cette
année et donc j'ai longuement vous
parler c'est un signal peu un bison futé
de l'électricité lorsque signal et rouge
eh bien il faudra qu'on engage
collectivement des baisses volontaire de
consommation ça c'est la première couche
puis il ya trois autres mesures de
sauvegarde la première celle
interruptible it et des grands
industriels français rte est sous
contrat avec grosse dizaine de gros
électro intensifs ils sont rémunérés
pour pouvoir être coupé on peut les
couper en 5 secondes et en 5 secondes on
est capable d'abattre la consommation de
1,2 gigawatts alors pardon je vais
utiliser quelques unités 1 2 giga watts
et la puissance et pour vous donnez donc
une idée la consommation
électrique à la pointe lors d'un hiver
normal c'est 80 100 gigawatts vous voir
jusqu'à 90 donc c'est pour vous donner
une proportion le record de france et
102 gigawatts il ya quelques années
une fois qu'on a passé ce deuxième ce
deuxième les cheveux ont deux
sauvegardes on est capable de baisser de
5% l'attention sur l'ensemble des
réseaux de distribution français ça
c'est transparent pour les français si
vous aviez encore une ampoule à filament
j'espère que désormais dans cette
institution est chez vous n'avez plus
que des led vous l'auriez vu trembloter
et baisser légèrement d'intensité
mais ça ça nous fait donc économiser de
la consommation et enfin en ultime en
cours la procédure de délestage
quand on parle beaucoup à mon avis trop
c'est à dire des coupures organisé de
temporaire tournante par tranche de deux
heures des consommateurs qui sont
raccordés au réseau de distribution
le but est bien évidemment content de ne
pas y recourir
aussi cet hiver
l'ensemble de ces mesures et de ses
quatre couches de mesures de sauvegarde
qu'on active successivement lorsque les
marchés n'arrive pas à bien équilibrer
le système électrique ont pour objectif
de ne jamais être en situation de black
out le black out sais pas du tout ce
dont j'ai parlé le black out c'est la
perte de contrôle du système électrique
et c'est son effondrement donc les
mesures de sauvegarde c'est pour ces
pour éviter le black out
alors j'en viens au tableau
je vous ai dit que
on avait construit trois scénarios de
production et d'un port le scénario
central qui est bleu moyens et puis deux
variantes une scénario de production
dégradé du fait d'une pénurie gazière
sévère et puis un scénario haut avec une
hypothèse centrale de 40 gigawatts de
nucléaire au 1er décembre 5 entre 1er
janvier et on a croisé ces scénarios de
production et d'un port avec des des
types divers
un hiver chaud un hiver médian moyens va
le dire en français filière conformes
aux normales saisonnières
un hiver froid et un hiver très froid
et à chaque fois on s'est demandés en
probabilité combien il y avait de
chances qu'on tire des signaux et cohade
rouge donc on a compté en nombre de
signaux et cohade rouge alors qu'est ce
qu'un signal ecowatt rouge
ça veut dire que le système électrique
est très tendue et que des coupures sont
inévitables si nous ne baissons pas
notre consommation ça veut dire ça a
signalé qu à trouver alors je vais le
redire pour que ce soit bien clair et
pour que le tableau soit compris dit
autrement donc rte prévoit des coupures
sauf si et le dossier très important la
consommation baissent de manière
volontaire et de manière substantielle
j'ai l'impression d'être clair
alors cette analyse elle nous permet de
tirer trois grands enseignements je vais
pas vous détailler chacune des douze
cases
le premier enseignement c'est que si
l'hiver est doux vous n'entendrez
probablement pas parler de nous
ce sera une bonne nouvelle pour vous et
pour nous
sauf quelques jours de signaler qu
atrous dans le scénario dégradé
d'importation due à une crise gazière
seiler
le deuxième enseignement c'est que si
les conditions météo de l'hiver ne
s'écarte pas trop des normales de saison
le risque de déséquilibre est faible
c'est ce que révèle la médiane de nos
simulations ans le nombre de signaux
ecowatt rouge probable et bah
strictement inférieure à 5 sur la
période je rappelle que la période dure
six mois et qu'un signal ecowatt rouge
concerne un jour
donc c'est strictement inférieure à 5
sauf dans notre scénario dégradé vous
voyez que il peut atteindre 2 6 à 12 à
une douzaine de signaux ces situations
là
ça constitue la très grande majorité des
situations probable pour l'hiver qui
vient
statistiquement
je le redis différemment pour être bien
compris la très grande majorité des
situations que nous anticipons
n'envisage que quelques signaux écho à
trouve sur les six mois de l'hiver dont
les proportions que vous voyez juste
derrière moi ok
ça c'était mon deuxième enseignement le
troisième enseignement c'est que si
l'hiver est très froid
là tout le monde qu'on soit que le
risque de déséquilibre est beaucoup plus
important parce que les français ont
besoin de plus d'énergie ne serait ce
que parce qu'ils se chauffent plus
et l'ordre de vendeurs du nombre de
signaux ecowatt rouge peut atteindre la
dizaine sur la période sauf dans le
scénario dégradé où la situation de
déséquilibre peut devenir plus
fréquentes et atteindre une trentaine de
signaux ecobat rouge
je le vois sur mon écran devant moi
maintenant ça marche
alors bien yves herman le risque c'est
que tout le monde se concentre sur la
case en bas à droite qui comporte de 20
de 20 à 28 donc activation probable du
signalé qu atre rouge
à cet égard ce serait quand même une
erreur de se concentrer sur cette casse
parce que c'est une situation c'est une
situation extrême ça fait partie des
situations les plus improbables
ça s'appelle une queue de distribution
c'est un scénario qui existe mais c'est
un saint ou qui est très improbable
comme tous les scénarios d'extrême
d'ailleurs
certes il existe une situation très
tendue
où le risque est largement
et est largement accrue dans le scénario
dégradé de production mais elle se
matérialise
dans un cas de cumul d'aléas très
défavorable une consommation non sobre
une météo très froide associé à une
crise gazière sévère qui a un impact sur
les centrales à gaz en europe et en
france
ou alternativement une remise en service
du parc nucléaire qui serait encore plus
dégradée que notre scénario central
bref c'est un cumul d'hypothèses
qui nous fait dire que cette situation
est très un problème même si elles
existent
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
la chance d'avoir un hiver très froid
correspond en espérance à moins d'une
chance sur 10
et c'est une probabilité qu on
croiserait avec la probabilité qui est
une crise gazière sévère ce qui n'est
pas encore le cas parce que nous avons
des stocks
que ça ait un impact sur les centrales à
gaz en europe et que ça influe sur les
imports d'électricité vers la france
c'est une probabilité qui n'est pas
calculable mais vous concevez que tout
ça conduit à une très faible probabilité
de ce scénario même s'il existe
mais c'est intéressant d'étudier ça
parce que tous deux mènent sa pointe de
deux choses c'est que les deux gros
points de vigilance pour l'hiver c'est
la disponibilité du parc nucléaire
et c'est le fonctionnement normal des
marchés en europe
alors j'ai insisté sur ce que veut dire
fonctionnement normal du marché en
europe il faut que les échanges
fonctionnent absolument comme d'habitude
je parle pas d'une solidarité spécifique
mais simplement du maintien du système
des changes et du respect par l'ensemble
des pays d'europe du droit communautaire
c'est de ça dont je parle et quand je
parle d'un fonctionnement normal je
parle de ça il s'agit pas de demander
aux autres pays de se priver pour nous
voilà pour mon premier message alors mon
deuxième message et vous voyez les
ordres de grandeur des signaux et cohade
rouge qui sont pas considérables c'est
que quelle que soit la situation le
risque de déséquilibre dont on parle il
a plusieurs caractéristiques la première
c'est qu'à chaque fois ça porte que sur
quelques poissons de la consommation
d'électricité on n'est pas dans des
trous de consommation on n'est pas dans
des manque d'énergie de 40%
dans la plupart des cas le manque
d'énergie que traduit un signal est qu à
trousser de 1 à 5% de la consommation
d'électricité
au pire ça peut aller jusqu'à 15% dans
notre scénario extrême
la deuxième caractéristique c'est que le
risque de ce manque d'énergie ce qui ne
porte jamais sur des jours entiers il se
porte à deux moments de la journée sur
le plateau du matin
là où en isère désormais y un premier
pic en fait c'est un plateau c'est un
pic plein de 8 heures à 13 heures et sur
le pic du soir qui est le traditionnel
pic de consommation en france à 19h00
au moment où vous avez superposition des
consommations tertiaire et des commerces
pendant que les français ont commencé à
rentrer chez eux rohff et
puisque on parlera cuisine tout à leur
faudra manger
et le message numéro trois c'est le plus
important contre une des ordres de
grandeurs je viens de donner c'est qu'on
peut écarter une large partie des
risques si on s'inscrit dans le scénario
et c'est sûr et si on est très
volontariste sur la sobriété de telle
sorte qu'on pourrait même traversé un
hiver froid
je pèse mes mots
c'est pourquoi moi il me semble que la
bonne disponibilité du nucléaire le
fonctionnement normal des marchés
d'électricité j'insiste là dessus c'est
absolument structure
la sobriété et la bonne gestion des pics
de consommation doit devenir alain un
objectif collectif
c'est comme ça que nous estimons que
nous évacuerons l'essentiel des risques
de coupure cet été cet hiver pardon
alors ça me permet de conclure sur les
leviers d'action qui sont finalement sur
la consommation est en fait c'est pour
ça que dans notre modèle on n'a pas
considéré que le plan de sobriété avait
un effet parce qu'on a voulu modéliser
des monde dans lequel la consommation
était plate pour voir les efforts de
sobriété qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse
et donc les de levier basse et la
sobriété d'abord donc la sobriété c'est
moins consommer de manière régulière en
volume
c'est le plan qui est engagée par le
gouvernement
et c'est le premier levier c'est évident
il faut le faire et puis le deuxième
levier c'est la flexibilité lors des
pointes parce que le système électrique
c'est des crus les plus aidés pointe
quand on en parlera bientôt et on a la
possibilité d'améliorer considérablement
la situation et d'être beaucoup plus
résilient si on parvient à faire en
sorte que la france réagisse à nos
signaux d'ecowatt rouge et de faire les
bons gestes au bon moment lorsqu'on est
en pique je sais pas combien temps j'en
suis monsieur le président en 29 minutes
alors je vais je vais
vais sacrifier la présentation des
cohade et on ne reviendra pendant les
questions si vous en êtes d'accord
je vais juste vous vous présentez une
slide juste avant de terminer sa je vais
incarner mon propos sur il faut faire de
la sobriété et donc il faut il faut
répondre aussi à l'éco atrous
on vous a simulé au ici un diagnostic
d'un hiver froid très froid
dans lequel on aurait un parc de
production nucléaire dans notre scénario
central et qui probable ''serait une
trentaine d'heures de délestage sur
l'hiver
si on fait un plan sobriété les effets
de ce plan sobriété
et ben ils sont notables puisque on voit
qu'après un plan soubrier t le nerd le
monde heures de délestage probabilité
ils descendent autour de 10 sur l'hiver
et si à cela on ajoute une bonne
réactivité aux signalé qu à trouve c'est
à dire quand le joueur est rouge je fais
les gestes pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
coupure la probabilité de de délester
sur l'hiver elle tend vers zéro vous le
voyez
dans modo et ses tissus de nos modèles
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur la
synthèse de notre analyse de sécu
d'appro sur le président on m'a fait
trois minutes de suspension de séance
c'est ce que vous m'accordez les trois
minutes supplémentaires à mon crédit aux
vôtres tout à fait je voulais encore
puisque on avait 10 35 minutes donc
merci monsieur le président
alors
je vais vous montrer de slide une
première sur comment marche
notre
le dispositif ecowatt donc on va
s'arrêter là lorsque je vous dis qu'il
faut faire de la sobriété vous avez sous
les yeux une courbe de charge de l'hiver
la sobriété ça doit prendre deux formes
je fais des économies moyennes d'énergie
et d'électricité donc ça va tu as et la
courbe c'est ce qui est au dessus de moi
à gauche mais je peux aussi décalé
régulièrement mais consommation pour les
positionner au bon moment c'est la
logique des heures pleines et des heures
creuses un des ballons d'eau chaude qui
chauffe la nuit mais c'est aussi une
question d'habitude je peux décider que
désormais je ne ferai plus que mes
lessive soit 16 heures soit après 21h
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle sobriété
et puis nonobstant la sobriété il peut y
avoir des mondes où il ya quand même des
pics d'électricité qu'on aurait du mal à
passer et là nous on tire le signal
d'alarmé c'était quoi troubler il faut
que les français fassent des gestes
supplémentaires à deux moments de la
journée je vous ai dit 8h 13h d'une part
et 18h 20h d'autres pas alors le signal
est quoi on va y passer directement
c'est assez simple c'est nous qui
donnons de la visibilité aux français
trois jours à l'avance ces trois
couleurs que tout le monde comprend vert
orange rouge vert tout va bien orange
des échos ges sont bienvenus parce que
les marges tendre vers zéro rouge si on
ne fait pas d'actions d'économies de
consommation volontaire il y aura des
coupures
c'est un site web on a prévu une
connexion pour que l'ensemble des
industriels qui veulent se connecter de
manière automatique alors process
industriel et par exemple le chauffage à
travers la gtb des bâtiments puisse le
faire et c'est en train de prendre bien
évidemment les fournisseurs
d'électricité
français en tout cas les trois plus gros
se sont engagés à relayer ce signal à
leurs clients pour que l'ensemble des
françaises soit alertée de ces alertes
voilà je pense qu'on va aller
directement donc à la slide de ce que
pour eux les effets d'un plan sobriété
on vous renverra tout ce qu'on a calculé
sur
la sobriété du chauffage qu'est-ce
qu'elle pourrait gagner en puissance et
c'est
complètement à la fin est ce qu'on peut
aller complètement l'infant colline
voilà
l'illustration on a essayé de modéliser
un plan sobriété auquel on a rajouté les
fn a signalé qu as tu suivi par un
certain nombre d'entreprises français
vous voyez que
à la pointe de 19 heures qui a une
pointe critique nous estimons qu'on
serait capable d'aller chercher 4
gigawatts d'économie g d'énergie grâce à
la sobriété à 19 heures + 5 grâce à la
réponse aux signalé qu atre rouge qui
vous l'avez vu dans la plupart des
scénarios n'arrivera pas 70 fois durant
l'hiver c'est quelquefois pendant
l'hiver mais ce jour là il faut être au
rendez-vous et si on atteint
ses 9 gigawatts de d'économie de
consommation ça nous fait passer
l'essentiel des risques
l'essentiel des risques et presque tous
nous on pense que les français sont
capables d'aller plus loin que ses 9
gigawatts qu'on a modélisé on pense
qu'on peut aller substantiellement plus
loin s'il ya une mobilisation nationale
d'ici 1er novembre voilà c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire
j'ai passé à tour la parole à thomas qui
va essayer de
nous parler de quelques paramètres sur
les prix même si j'essayais pardon
thomas d'aller à la vitesse de la
lumière
je suis président mesdames et messieurs
les députés
gros challenge puisque la partie pris en
3 minutes
difficiles allait en quatre ans 4 bon
alors j'espère
alors la partie prix pourquoi c'était un
engagement de notre part vis-à-vis des
parties prenantes qu'on a consultés dans
le cadre de l'élaboration de ce travail
parce que la crise dont on parle la
crise énergétique
on parle de risques sur la sécurité
d'approvisionner ces risques qui ne se
sont pas matérialisées sont des
probabilités par contre les condyles les
conséquences économiques les
répercussions économiques elles sont
déjà là et c'est l'augmentation des prix
notamment l'augmentation des prix de
marché à terme donc je vais faire très
vite là dessus les consommateurs payent
un tarif à la fin mais ce tarif même
s'il ya des protections même si à la
reine même si elles bouclier tarifaire
ces tarifs sont influencés à terme par
le prix de marché le prix de marché qui
petit à petit influence et ira et
risquent de tirer à la hausse ces prix
là donc c'est important de comprendre si
les primes marché intègre la bonne
information s'ils sont fondés sur les
visions probabilité qui correspondent à
ce qu'on attend pour l'hiver alors que
s'est-il passé au cours des derniers
autour des derniers mois voilà vous
voyez ici la courbe rouge sont les prix
de marché à terme pour le quatrième
trimestre 2022 j'aurais pu prendre des
bus 2023 c'était pareil la partie grise
ce sont les coûts de production projetée
des dernières centrales électriques des
centrales électriques les plus chers
donc on voit trois trois choses première
chose
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
c'est d'abord les prix du gaz essai
avant la guerre en ukraine ça a commencé
avant
c'est la première période deuxième chose
bien sûr la guerre en ukraine a conduit
à amplifier le mouvement notamment
lorsqu'il y a eu les les les baisses sur
de livraisons russes sur les gazoducs
mais on voit aussi à partir du printemps
été et c'est ça le point central dans
notre analyse qui a commencé à y avoir
un creux entre les deux courbes dit
autrement le prix de l'électricité
évolue bien toujours avec celui du gaz
plus le prix du gaz augmente pub plus
celui de l'électricité augmentent mais à
compter du printemps on peut considérer
que les mecs que les marchés ont
commencé à intégrer autre chose en
réalité ils ont commencé à intégrer une
une anticipation cette anticipation
c'est celle qu'il ya un problème cet
hiver qui a un problème cet hiver
spécifique à la france c'est ça qui
s'est passé et donc si on va très vite
envoyé ça c'est la façon dont
fonctionner les marchés avant le prix de
l'électricité c'était le prix des moyens
thermiques pourquoi les modèles
thermiques parce qu'en europe c'est
toujours une centrale à gaz où une
centrale au charbon qui est nécessaire
pour faire fonctionner le système
électrique a toujours besoin d'une à
partir de cette année on a vu une
déconnexion voilà c'est ce qui s'affiche
ici chez eux et je vais très vite les
prix de marché se sont envolés au dessus
de cette zone et ça c'est le risque
c'est la prévention du risque qui encore
une fois est très spécifique à la france
alors pourquoi cette appréhension du
risque et pourquoi ça s'est fait au
printemps ça me permet de venir sur deux
paramètres importants de l'analyse
l'hydraulique et le nucléaire peut-être
de préciser les hypothèses on a
considéré donc sur l'hydraulique on n'en
parle pas souvent mais effectivement on
est dans une année où le pro de la
production hydraulique car général entre
60 et 65 térawattheures elle a dit
térawattheures en dessous c'est qu'à
moins 15% ça s'est passé plutôt l'été et
l'automne pour on en est sortie de
l'hiver plutôt avec des stocks qui était
bien remplie hiver doux le dernier plus
comportement prudent des exploitants par
contre cet été pas d'apport hydraulique
du coup faible production du coup
tensions sur le système à l'automne il y
aura toujours une faible production
pourquoi parce que les exploitants gère
pour que cet hiver on puisse utiliser à
plein le levier hydraulique
donc voilà à l'été on était dans une
situation où il y avait un an guy
drollet qui était particulièrement
criant sur le nucléaire en fait c'est
pareil c'est à l'été que l'écart entre
le nominal et la situation qu'on a
rencontré était le plus important
l'été il manquait 15 à 20 gigawatts de
disponibilité du nucléaire alors bien
sûr c'est normal que des réacteurs soit
à l'arrêt au printemps elle était à
l'automne il s'arrête tout le temps à
cette période là pour faire des
rechargement de combustible ou des
travaux de maintenance et deuxièmement
c'est plutôt de bonnes politiques
d'avoir fait des économies de
combustible cet été de sorte à ce que
certains réacteurs soient là cet hiver
donc ça c'est favorable à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
mais cet été on avait quand même une
situation qui était très tendue parce
qu'il manquait beaucoup de nucléaire
donc que les prix est monté cet été ça
c'est plutôt normal la question c'est de
savoir si le march les marchés
anticipent bien ce qui va se passer
l'hiver prochain et or voici la courbe
que nous on a considéré pour l'hiver
je vais insister vraiment sur deux
points c'est pas une courbe naïve on n'a
pas pris les estimations les plus
optimistes
c'est pas la concaténation des
déclarations centrale par centrale sur
les registres de transparence on a des
abattements dès qu'ils sont basés sur
des lois statistiques et les prudences
spécifique pour les réacteurs corrosion
sous contrainte on pense qu'il vaut
mieux le prendre comme ça et voilà vous
voyez cette courbe parce que la deuxième
caractéristique c'est que cette
prévision est publique et au cours de
l'automne et de l'hiver vous pourrez
vous référer à cette cour pour savoir si
on évolue plutôt vers le haut ou plutôt
vers le bas du spectre et sao ça nous
permettra de contrôler et de piloter
vers où on est en train de s'acheminer
donc voila nous pour l'hiver on a pris
ce type d' analyse mais même avec ces
prudence vous voyez que la situation sur
l'hiver par rapport au nominal il y aura
moins d'écart entre la l'aller 45
gigawatt qu'on s'attend à avoir en
janvier et le nominal que durant l'été
dit autrement
nous pensons que les prix de marché qui
sont projetés pour l'hiver prochain
traduisent une appréhension d'une
situation qui sera pire que ce que nous
sommes susceptibles de rencontrer
même en intégrant une vision prudente
parce que vous avez pied choisi clady on
n'a pas pris une vision béate on s'est
confronté à des codes probabilité donc
vu de nous aujourd'hui les marchés
intègrent une prime de risque très élevé
qui correspond implicitement un niveau
de risque et plus de deux fois
supérieurs aux scénarios un autre
scénario du pire c'est à lire un
scénario qui serait dégradée à la fois
sur la production avec une hypothèse
assez brutal sur les échanges et dans un
univers très contraignant n'a pas eu
l'hiver 2010 2011 pour ans on l'a pris
parce que il était très fort en décembre
en décembre ça une période très tôt par
leur part au système et au moment où on
risque d'avoir des retards encore de
réacteurs nucléaires donc on sait bien
confronté à une situation qui est tendu
la conclusion de cette analyse a que
vraiment j'ai brossé à grands traits on
savait expliquer les prix spot cet été
mais les prix atteints sur les marchés à
terme ne nous sommes pas reflété
correctement les perspectives anticipé
pour l'hiver prochain tout se passe
comme si le marché avait brutalement
basculer d'une situation ils
n'anticipaient pas du tout le risque de
défaillance à une situation à laquelle
il s'est positionné par rapport à un
scénario vraiment du pire en tout cas le
pire du pire même j'oserais dire
deuxième chose ce niveau le niveau de
risque qui révélait par cette analyse
ne permet pas de justifier ses prix même
en intégrant un risque de défaillance
même en ne prévoyant pas d'évolution à
la baisse de la demande alors qu'on
s'attend quand même à avoir des effets
du plan sobriété et même en considérant
une disponibilité du parc nucléaire que
l'on revendique comme prudentes c'est à
dire inférieure à l'agrégation des
données déclarées centrale par centrale
j'ajouterai pour terminer que les
actions sur la consommation qui sont
menées dans le cadre du plan sobriété
bien sûr ça améliore la sécurité
d'approvisionnement mais ça va également
contribuer à faire baisser les prix et à
faire baisser la facture énergétique
donc on pense vraiment que ce sont des
choses qu'il faut absolument poursuivre
voilà
monsieur le président nous avons terminé
nous avons légèrement dérapé de quelques
3 4 minutes pardon de cela très bien
merci monsieur le président merci à vous
également sur la partie prix économie
merci pour vos réponses complètes et
cette présentation je crois très clair
qui pose clairement les hypothèses les
scénarios essaie de les quantifier d
expliquer façon la plus claire possible
c'est vraiment l'un petit donc merci
très utile je vous propose de passer
aux orateurs du groupe
différents groupes je vous rappelle le
fonctionnement à nouveau quatre minutes
de prise de parole par groupe l'orateur
du groupe a la possibilité de prendre le
temps qu'il souhaite jusqu'à trois
minutes je tiens à préciser à 3 minutes
je coupe et vous avez de votre côté la
possibilité de répondre jusqu'à 4
minutes j'ai président vous avez croqué
juste ici ne m'en voulez pas je suis
assez strict sur le temps mais il faut
bien qu'on finisse et donc à quatre
minutes je couperai donc en fonction de
ce que vous voulez ce comme temps de
réponse les députés vous pouvez répondre
à hauteur de 4 minutes je vous propose
de commencer avec maud brégeon groupe
renaissance
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur pied choisi que de venir nous
présenter vos scénarios sur le passage
de l'hiver on vous l'avait dit à court
terme il repose en bonne partie sur la
disponibilité effective du parc
nucléaire et donc sur le respect des
planning de maintenance vous avez
scénario qu'un tech des hypothèses sur
la disponibilité
qui sont significativement plus basse
que celle d'edf comment est ce que vous
les expliquer qu'elle marche prenez-vous
sur quel historique s'est construit et
comment peut-être est-ce que vous
expliquez que ses marges ne soit pas
graduellement intégré dans la prévision
communiquée au marché de la durée des
arrêts par l'exploitant deuxième point
en temps normal on a des périodes de
vigilance qui sont concentrées sur
janvier février cet automne ça démarre
dès octobre avec un nucléaire à 35
gigawatts en novembre qu'est ce qui
amène un scénario où la sécurité
d'approuver exceptionnellement en
vigilance si tôt et puis enfin une
question d'un peu plus long terme
pour ouvrir quelques perspectives
dernier bilan prévisionnel moyen terme
prévoyez une nette amélioration de la
situation à compter de 2025 période à
laquelle on devrait retrouver des marges
du fait notamment de nouvelles
interconnexions et de nouveaux moyens de
production est ce que vous maintenez ses
prévisions je vous remercie monsieur le
président
monsieur le président je n'ai plus
qu'une minute 15 du tout madame région
madame agent a pris une minute 15 avec
très raisonnable vous avez donc tout le
reste du temps jusqu'à 4 alors madame la
députée j'ai commencé par votre dernière
question nous nous publions notre
notre bilan prévisionnel plutôt à
échéance au décennale en mars prochain
et là nous allons intégrer l'ensemble
des effets de la crise pour se
reprojeter et pour couvrir le jalon 2025
2026 2028 donc vous aurez une étude
précise à ce à ce moment là pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a une période de vigilance
qui commence très tôt je crois que ce
serait bien qu'on mette la slide sur la
disponibilité du parc nucléaire parce
que aujourd'hui le parc nucléaire est
très bas et vous voyez que ce qui est
stratégique c'est la vitesse à laquelle
les tranches nucléaires vont revenir sur
le réseau bien évidemment quelques
semaines de retard on part de là on est
mi septembre donc on part de la jonction
entre la courbe orange et la courbe
rouge
tout le monde voit qu'on parle d'une
disponibilité très basses et que l'enjeu
n'est pas seulement le sommet qui va
être atteint au 1er janvier mais l'enjeu
c'est la vitesse de remontée et est-ce
qu'il y aura assez disponibilité
nucléaire dans les semaines où on peut
on peut commencer à rencontrer des
bulles de froid et bulles de froid est
là elles peuvent arriver fin octobre ou
début novembre et c'est ça l'enjeu c'est
à dire en fait c'est à la fois un enjeu
de maximum atteint en janvier où on
concentre les probabilités de froid mais
c'est aussi à l'enjeu de vitesse de
remontée de cette disponibilité du parc
bien évidemment si la courbe était était
déformé en bombe ben on serait beaucoup
plus protégés sur les mois d'octobre
novembre qu'on va l'être aujourd'hui
alors sur la question des prudences
prince ta parole à thomas verhaeghe
qui a deux minutes comme moi
j'ai souvenir les quatre minutes pour
les prudents on a pris trois paquets un
paquet de prudence pour les réacteurs
ils sont supposés revenir dans les
prochains jours prochaines semaines on a
une loi statistique il ya des lois
statistiques qu'on peut faire tout
simplement en observant les écarts sur
le passé donc on utilise nos doigts
statistiques sont basées sur
l'observation tout simplement on fait un
deuxième paquet pour les réacteurs qui
font l'essentiel de leur maintenance au
cours du mois de septembre octobre
novembre et un certain qu'ils seront pas
encore partis en indisponibilité donc
c'est ce paquet là qui va être clé pour
le mois de mai mois de novembre et
décembre et puis on a pris des prudences
voilà qui sont plutôt à dire d'expert
pour les réacteurs sur le pour la
corrosion sous contrainte pour cela au
lit les déclarations les déclarations
d'edf on sait ce qu'ils sont priorisés
et donc on les a traités comme ça mais
je voudrais dire que notre notre
prévision centrale correspond quand même
à la fourchette qui a été donné par edf
aux marchés 280-300 plutôt dans le bas
de la fourchette mais quand même c'est
dans la fourchette donc en fait le
traitement statistique se comprend
également par rapport à leurs
informations je me permets juste ce
matin en un lieu d f donc son président
qui est venu nous voir la prévision
sénat ouverture le 5 réacteurs en
septembre et 2,5 en octobre et de 7 en
novembre c'est bien ce que vous vous
avez également de l'autre côté on y
partie de ça et ensuite on applique des
lois statistiques d'accord
très bien je crois que ça va juste et
quelques questions je donne tout de
suite la parole donc à yale ménages que
tu es rassemblement national
merci monsieur le président monsieur
piechaczyk l' équilibre des réseaux et
nous le savons une priorité du rte
afin que sa mission de transport et
livraison soit assurée pourtant le choix
délibéré d'un focus sur les énergies
intermittentes va à l'encontre de cet
impératif d' équilibre à ce paradoxe
s'ajoute l'état catastrophique du parc
nucléaire dont le taux de disponibilité
n'a jamais été aussi bas aujourd'hui
nous nous interrogeons sur la notion d
d'effacement énergétique qui est
invoquée comme la seule solution pour
répondre à une situation de raréfaction
des ressources et de marché haussier si
nous comprenez si nous comprenons bien
ce terme il s'agit d'un processus de
diminution de la quantité d'énergie
consommée d'un point de vue pragmatique
il s'agit de coupures organisée nous
comprenons que vous disposez de quatre
leviers pour réaliser cet effacement
l'efficacité énergétique soit
l'investissement sur des technologies
moins énergivores le lissage de la
courbe de charge c'est-à-dire le jeu sur
le timing de la consommation afin
d'inciter à consommer par exemple lors
des heures creuses l'effacement
dynamique sur le marché périphrase
pudique pour cautionner l'augmentation
des coûts l'énergie afin d'inciter à
réduire les usages les mesures de
sauvegarde autant dire la coupure de
l'accès à l'électricité que vous appelez
non moins pudiquement délestage partiel
sélectif
cette politique de l'effacement que vous
proposez repose essentiellement sur la
contrainte du consommateur par le biais
du tarif et l'arbitrage des coupures
selon nous vous vous résignez à la face
à la fatalité et invoquer des concepts
très spécieux pour justifier cette
résignation alors vous pouvez nous
expliquer si vous disposez d'une marge
de manoeuvre réel quantifiables pour
mettre en oeuvre cet effacement
indépendamment de la pression tarifaire
que vous proposez comme un recours avant
la coupure
comment la france sixième puissance
mondiale à laquelle on enviait le bas
coûts de l'énergie et l'excellence des
savoir-faire peut-elle être à ce point
précarisés pour qu'on envisage l'arrêt
de la fourniture électrique à certains
clients à certaines heures
n'est ce pas précisément votre mission
que d'empêcher pareil fatalité en
oeuvrons pour l'équilibré la
disponibilité et non pas les règles
l'irrégularité
l'indisponibilité et le chantage
tarifaire
quelle confiance les français devraient
vous accordez alors même que vous avez
directement participé d'abord avec
monsieur ayrault puis avec monsieur
hollande à ce qui nous a mis dans cette
situation merci
monsieur le président vous avez la
visibilité de gérer le temps comme vous
souhaitez jusqu'à 4
madame la députée merci de votre
interpellation
je suis bien placé pour dire que le
système électrique ne disposent plus de
marges
ils disposent plus de marges parce que
je vous ai dit que la france avait fait
des choix climatique parce que la france
a signé des engagements internationaux
et qui est avec la france et dans
l'union et qu'elle a pris des
engagements dans l'union et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a signé par on a
fermé par exemple les centrales au fioul
la france a été trop longue sur les
énergies renouvelables je les dis devant
cette commission il y a quelques mois
lorsque j'ai présenté le futur
énergétique 2050 la france est en retard
sur le p r et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça a commencé à faire baiser
noir à la suite de quoi la france a
perdu d'autres marges en matière de
systèmes électriques tout le monde le
comprend et je ne sais pas si c'est de
la faute de quelqu'un il ya eu la crise
du coc vide qui a désorganisé le
planning de maintenance de l'appareil
électronucléaire français parce que tout
simplement donc on n'a pas réussi à
faire de la maintenance pendant six mois
il ya eu cette découverte de la
corrosion sous contrainte qui a conduit
à l'arrêt de tranche pour des raisons de
sûreté et c'était bien que ces tranches
s'arrête pour des raisons de sûreté et
puis la gare en ukraine qui génère une
crise gazière et qui génère une
explosion des prix de l'électricité
aussi ça aussi effectivement je ne sais
pas qu'il pouvait le prévoir
donc oui effectivement il ya eu des
sujets structurelles historique dans la
politique énergétique française mais il
ne faut pas oublier que la situation de
0 marche dans laquelle nous sommes et
notamment sur le parc nucléaire et du
hodh au désordre que posco ville qui a
été qu'ils ont eu un impact industriel
absolument considérable et à la
corrosion sous contrat c'est monsieur
président qui est une découverte pour
vous pour moi et pour le groupe edf
merci beaucoup monsieur l'aîné du groupe
elle est fille
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président de rte les députés du groupe
elle est fille nue prend quelques
craintes sur les conditions
d'approvisionnement énergétique pour cet
hiver et de manière générale sur notre
modèle énergétique au-delà des
conséquences de la guerre russe en
ukraine cette situation de crise est
aussi liée à d'autres facteurs
premièrement on vient de le rappeler au
retard pris par la france sur les
énergies renouvelables contrairement à
ses voisins européens mais aussi d'une
part à la défaillance du nucléaire
confrontés au changement climatique
déficit d'eau et l'augmentation de sa
température et d'autre part à des
problèmes de sécurité des installations
notamment liée à la corrosion sous
contrainte problème qui a justifié la
fermeture de 12 réacteurs cet été
conduisant rendent la moitié du parc
nucléaire hors service face à cette
situation votre solution pour cet hiver
qui est celle reprise également par le
président de la république et la
commission européenne c'est celle de la
baisse de la consommation que vous venez
de nous présenter dont vous estimé
qu'elle devrait être de l'ordre de 15%
en situations météorologiques extrêmes
alors c'est la fourchette haute à une
solution basée sur le développement
d'éco gestes s'appuyant donc sur la
responsabilité individuelle de nos
concitoyens mais qui fait fi de toute
responsabilité collective celle de
l'état au premier chef l'objectif vous
semble-t-il réellement atteignable avec
ses stratégies le dispositif ecowatt il
suffira t-il concerne utile uniquement
les ménages ou aussi les entreprises et
les collectivités
nous sommes absolument convaincus de la
nécessité de construire une économie à
une société de la sobriété mais nous
pensons pour notre part que seul un
changement profond de modèle de
production et de consommation qui
nécessite une véritable planification
écologique permettra d'engager une
sobriété énergétique efficiente de
manière plus générale vous avez indiqué
dans la presse que cette crise d'un
constituer un puissant facteur de
transition nous sommes d'accord il est
temps d'examiner sérieusement les six
scénarios que vous avez présenté rte
avec le plan futur énergétique 2050
compte tenu des nombreuses difficultés
actuelles et futures du nucléaire ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il convient d'
actualiser vos différentes hypothèses en
estimant que le coût de l'énergie
nucléaire y est largement sous-évalué
avec un rendement devenu incertain par
ailleurs votre scénario n 03 propose une
augmentation de la durée de vie des
centrales
problème de sécurité convient d'évoquer
ne devrait-il pas nous faire renoncer à
cette possibilité enfin le bilan
énergétique de l'été ne devrait-il pas
nous conduire à privilégier votre
scénario n 02 100 % renouvelable et sans
nucléaire d'ici l'horizon 2050 merci
monsieur le président
monsieur le député vous vous avez fait
écho à notre étude futur énergétique qui
présente six scénarios de production
d'électricité en france sur lequel je ne
prendrai jamais partie puisque
nous prenons parti ni pour les nerfs ni
pour le nucléaire nous mettons sur la
table des scénarios de mix électrique
nous estimons que c'est à la
représentation nationale et à l'exécutif
de prendre les décisions de ce que doit
être le mix électrique français demain
les scénarios qui sont sur la table
représentent toutes les tendances de la
société française il ya des scénarios
100% renouvelable il ya des scénarios
avec beaucoup de nucléaire ils sont tous
accessibles et donc effectivement c'est
à la représentation nationale on
dialogue avec l'exécutif de prendre ce
genre de décision rt éclaire le débat
public est et la décision politique mais
se sait sûrement pas à moi d'indiquer
quels scénarios je préfère et le cal est
préférable pour la france vous avez donc
indiqué que l'unique levier qu'on
mobilisaient pour passer cet hiver
c'était la baisse de consommation
réponse est oui mais moi je voudrais
bien qu'on me propose
d un accroissement du parc de production
qui permettra à la france de produire
plus d'électricité dans un mois
on peut accélérer les énergies
renouvelables et sera donc un effet dans
un an ou deux mais le parc de production
d'électricité de cet hiver on le connaît
déjà il est là il est déjà bâtie je dis
pas que dans trois ans il y aura pas des
nouveaux champs offshore
les centrales nucléaires fonctionneront
mieux c'est sûr mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous prenons la production
d'électricité telle qu'elle est et on
regarde ce problème en face une fois
qu'on a regardé ce problème en face oui
nous développons des économies nous
faisons appel à l'as à la solidarité
parce que nous estimons qu'il est
préférable qu'on soit tous solidaires
plutôt que de faire subir à quelques-uns
des coupures
merci beaucoup et et pardon à l'arrêt
peut-être
monsieur bolo du modem
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président au pied physique je
commencerai par vous féliciter pour
votre travail de modélisation la qualité
des résultats que vous apportez est
certaine et cd sont également des
résultats précieux pour l'aide à la
décision et le contrôle que nous voulons
que nous devons réaliser je reviendrai
sur votre que le constat issu de vos
scénarisation qui montre que finalement
le risque de black out reste à écarter
mais que malgré tout ne peut être écarté
en revanche des limitations qui elle
reste possible qui montre qu'on est dans
une situation de vulnérabilité
je voudrais revenir sur le sujet du
réseau et de nos interconnexion avec nos
voisins européens plus ou moins immédiat
qui nous font appartenir à un réseau
européen global et jouets savoir un tel
réseau global relié avec d'autres pays
qui eux mêmes eh bien écoutez sont
assujettis à un certain nombre d'atouts
et de faiblesse de leur système de
production et ont leurs propres mesures
de sauvegarde et bien comment vous avez
considéré cette cette interconnexion
cette liaison avec des pays qui ont
leurs propres particularités dans votre
approche et est ce que finalement un
cumul de situations défavorables chez
des pays voisins plus ou moins proche
serait-il de nature à impacter notre
c'est notre situation nous en france par
un effet domino et quand je dis ça je
vais au-delà de ce que vous avez
souligné à plusieurs reprises qui est la
normalité du marché européen mais un
ensemble de situations défavorables chez
eux parce que leurs outils viendrait
devenir défaillant avec des situations
météo très particulière et peut-être des
stratégies de sauvegarde qui deviendrait
inopérantes
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur beaux lots j'en profite pour
rappeler parce que je pense que j'ai été
mal compris que le signaler qu at il
s'adresse aux collectivités
territoriales d'abord aux entreprises
aussi d'abord et enfin aux ménages et ce
n'est pas un signal qui a traversé au
ménage on mobilise les entreprises
d'abord parce que c'est là où on ira
faire de plus de gains et et comme j'ai
beaucoup parlé je passe la main à thomas
verhaeghe vous répondre sur les
interconnexions que ce boulot
alors
comment on a pris en compte la situation
des pays voisins là encore on a tenté de
partir de principes de prudence ont déjà
de ce qu'on en sait c'est au modélise
mode et ce qui se passe en europe
puisque effectivement c'est le système
métrique qui fonctionne comme un système
européen donc en fait si on faisait la
france tout seul on aurait un mauvais
résultat
donc on maudissent le parc de production
en allemagne en autriche en italie etc
on prend des prudences par exemple on
n'a pas pris en compte la décision
allemande de prolonger deux des trois
réacteurs nucléaires parce que les
récentes d'une part de l'autre parce
qu'on n'en connaît pas encore
concrètement les modalités deuxième
chose l'allemagne a annoncé la remise en
service d'un certain nombre de centrales
au charbon dans quelle proportion avec
quelle vitesse ses centrales qu'on va
fonctionner beaucoup ces dernières
années est ce qu'elles peuvent encore
bien fonctionné on a été prudent là
dessus par contre à la question est ce
que il peut y avoir un cumul de
situations défavorables
oui on l'a pris en compte c'est le
scénario dégradé le scénario dégradé c1
c'est à un scénario de limitation des
échanges et on a pris une hypothèse un
peu brutale en considérant que ce qui
pouvait conduire un certain nombre de
nos voisins à être en difficulté
c'était la pénurie gazière pourquoi
parce que en allemagne en italie ou dans
certains dans beaucoup de pays en
réalité le parc de production
d'électricité à base de gaz est très
important beaucoup plus qu'en france
donc si pénurie gazière il y a il peut y
avoir d une
- de production d'électricité à base de
gaz et la wii il pourrait y avoir un
effet sur les échanges c'est pour ça
qu'on a modélisé ce scénario ce scénario
dégradé après aujourd'hui on n'a pas
constaté du tout même l'hiver dernier
même en situation de tension de
problèmes sur les échanges au contraire
un la france qui est un pays qui
traditionnellement est extrêmement
exportateur d'électricité le plus gros
exportateur européen peut se retrouver
d'une année sur l'autre devenir un très
grand importateur et ça c'est quand même
le système européen d'interconnexion qui
le permet ça donne une fluidité et des
marges supplémentaires à chacun des pays
et c'est quand même très précieux dans
la situation de crise que nous vivons
très bien merci beaucoup madame
battistel le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du directoire nous avons
écouté à la fois votre conférence de
presse de ce matin et puis la
présentation très précise que vous nous
avez fait donc merci beaucoup donc on
comprend que vous fait reposer une part
importante de l'effet des mesures de
sauvegarde à la fois sur le signal
ecowatt rouge qui est le premier niveau
et puis sur les mesures de sobriété que
le gouvernement doit annoncer vous avez
également
précisé pourquoi la période de tension
commencera dès octobre novembre contre
janvier en année normale et vous nous
l'avez expliqué de manière très précise
dans votre introduction mais à deux
semaines de cette période finalement
puisque c'est demain nous ne connaissons
rien du plan de sobriété du gouvernement
et aucune campagne d'ampleur faisant la
promotion des cowboys a été lancé donc
la question est ce que nous sommes pas
un tout petit peu en retard et comment
on va en quinze jours faire en sorte que
cette tout cela soit approprié par à la
fois les entreprises mais aussi des
citoyens parce que même s'ils doivent
être appelés les derniers ils peuvent
aussi je pense contribuer à leur niveau
à aux efforts de sobriété qui peuvent
être faits c'est à la fois bénéfique
pour passer l'hiver et puis c'est aussi
bénéfique pour le climat sur le long
terme si on prend tous et toutes de
bonnes habitudes donc concernant sept
alertes ecowatt
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une
opportunité de mettre en oeuvre des
notifications je ne sais pas sur les
smartphones ou sûr en tout cas que cette
application soit diffusé le plus
largement possible et pas dans un milieu
très resserré la deuxième question vous
avez développé trois scénarii pour
l'hiver dégradé intermédiaires et et au
et vous êtes basé sur une hypothèse
normal de production des centrales de
gaz et de niveaux d'importation on a eu
une petite alerte notamment du côté de
la norvège qui a eu un discours un peu
inquiétant à ce sujet je comprends dans
vos propos qu'il n'y a pas matière à
s'inquiéter plus que ça et nous avons
plutôt entendu que vous étiez assez
entre guillemets optimistes et que les
doutes sera à la fois la remise en ligne
des réacteurs nucléaires que on pourrait
avoir et cette situation des changes et
notamment la question de la norvège
n'est pas une problématique extrêmement
forte dont vous pouvez vous nous leur
confirmer s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup
monsieur le président
merci de votre question madame battistel
moi je crois que sur ecowatt il n'est
pas trop tard on mobilise beaucoup
d'entreprises on signe des dizaines de
partenariats tous les jours et c'est là
comme je le disais à monsieur le député
qui a les plus gros levier on en signe
avec les grosses collectivités
territoriales alors bien sûr on aurait
pu commencer plus tôt mais
je crois que c'est en train de prendre
j'ajoute que c'est ça pas vocation à
être confidentielles sa vocation est un
signal relayée sur toute la presse
toutes les radios toutes les télés au
bulletin météo relayé par tous les
fournisseurs d'électricité
par edf par angie par total ça va
couvrir tous les français voilà donc ces
grande ampleur
alors concernant moi je ne peux pas me
prononcer sur le plan de souris étaient
du gouvernement j'en fais pas partie
simplement ce que je peux dire d'avant
je suis prise dans une société anonyme
qui a une délégation de service public
mais je suis maman de l'exécutif
comme vous l'avez constaté simplement ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est
toujours difficile de faire une campagne
pour baisser le chauffage quand on est
au moins d'août et qui fait 35,2 et
c'est que à un moment donné on on est
dans cette dent dans cette contradiction
là et là c'est une question de
communication
alors on n'est pas optimiste sur la sur
le productible nucléaire on n'est pas
optimiste sur le productive nucléaire on
est prudent et on l'a dit plusieurs fois
est-ce qu'on serait trop optimiste sur
les échanges européens non on dit juste
que c'est normal et ce serait normal que
mm dans les cas de crise l'ensemble des
pays respecte le droit communautaire
voilà ce qu'on dit
j'ai président c'est accessible madame
lr le groupe écologiste
oui merci je tenais d'abord à vous
remercier pour la clarté des
explications aussi bien sur
les légitimes interrogations sur le
possible de black out mais surtout sur
le fait que vous argumentez alimenter
les différents scénarios mettait en
exergue aussi notamment sur l'analyse
économique du prix et les effets que
nous avons déjà toutes et tous ressenti
sur le prix de l'électricité
notamment l'indisponibilité de la
majeure partie du parc nucléaire qui
forcément préoccupe l'ensemble du pays
j'avais plusieurs questions suite à
votre exposé d'abord faire remarquer et
ce n'est pas la première fois dans les
scénarisation de rte mais quand même de
vous démontrer que le meilleure
résilience de notre système énergétique
et bien la baisse des consommations et
donc la sobriété et qu'il ya là un axe
encore assez inexploité il est vrai que
le projet du gouvernement
tarde à sortir alors que c'est un axe
absolument majeur pour la bonne tension
sur notre réseau
des questions aussi sur l'application et
la diffusion des comètes vous en avez
donné quelques pistes en réponse pour
les entreprises des collectivités et
commence à peu comment envisagez vous
entrez dans la scénarisation quel volume
vous allez toucher et pouvoir toucher
pour que ça ait un impact considérable
sur le délestage aux heures de pointe
une question sur votre aperçu sur le
prix qui a déjà extrêmement augmenter
pour les entreprises pour les
collectivités mais aussi sur les
particuliers qui du coup ont déjà
renoncé à certaines dépenses
énergétiques en fermant des équipements
publics pour des collectivités mais des
particuliers ont également engagé à
marche forcée des travaux pour ne plus
dépendre des énergies fossiles
difficiles qui ont un prix qui
augmentent énormément est ce que vous
pouvez anticiper sa y compris sur
l'hiver prochain et puis
ensuite les différents scénarios vous
l'avez évoqué sur notamment vous aviez
un scénario sur la disponibilité du parc
nucléaire qui ont été faits sur le mix
énergétique français sans prendre en
compte les problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte et donc la fermeture de plus
de réacteurs faudrait-il ou actualisée
de ce fait et scénario que vous aviez
élaboré au printemps dernier
voilà monsieur le président madame je
vous laisse une minute trente merci
non il n'ya pas valeurs d'actualité
futur énergétique en revanche nous
actualisons les jalons 2030-2035 parce
que cela dans les trajectoires de
neutralité carbone peuvent être
perturbés par le contexte
macroéconomique activement des problèmes
de disponibilité sur le parc nucléaire
est ce que la meilleure résilience et de
baisser la consommation pour cet hiver
oui et de toute éternité oui parce que
dans futur énergétique nous avait dit
que nous avons dit que pour des
questions de neutralité carbone il
fallait aussi qu'on baisse notre
consommation donc dont baisser sa
consommation c'est toujours bon y
compris en électricité
quel volume ecowatt on a fait des
statistiques sur le nombre d'entreprises
qui serait capable de s'y impliquer nous
ce qu'on demande aux entreprises qui
signent la charte c'est des engagements
chiffrés on veut des volumes on veut le
l'engagement chiffré on veut pas de
greenwashing on veut de l'engagement
chiffré et sur les prix vous posez une
question sur les tarifs réglementés de
vente je crois qu'il ya une conférence
de presse de même la première ministre
cet après midi justement sur l'icc sur
ces questions et sur le bouclier
tarifaire est donc permettez moi
d'attendre ce qu'elle va nous dire avant
de pouvoir vous répondre
très bien monsieur molac pour le groupe
iott
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues sur le président donc j'ai une
question vous n'excluez pas qu'il y ait
des délestages est ce que ces délestages
peuvent être géographique puisque je me
souviens que dans le lit vers
1979 la bretagne avait été entièrement
en black out pendant une journée alors
comme on est mauvais esprit on a pensé
que c'est comme nous ne voulions pas de
centrale nucléaire à plogoff
on nous avait quelque peu puni mais donc
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un délestage
carrément géographique d'une partie de
la france qui soit dans le black out ou
pas ou est ce que vous estimez que ce
que vous prévoyez alors d'abord les
entreprises avec un certain nombre de
partenariats avec les entreprises qui
datent de loin pour éviter les pics de
consommation mais est ensuite les
institutions nous évitera ce genre de
choses
j'ai président est-ce qu'on ne coûtent
que la bretagne non rassurez nous comme
je suis enregistré je ne vais pas faire
de mauvaise blague parce qu'après je
pourrais être mal monté par des bretons
monsieur molac on va pas couper que la
bretagne d'ailleurs on a là on a
l'intention de ne pas couper du tout et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait la promotion de
la souveraineté d'une part et déco at
d'autre part et je suis sérieux s'il ya
une mobilisation nationale
nous sommes capables de passer ses
piques simplement il faudrait que tout
le monde s'y met ça relève d'une
mobilisation collective et à cet égard
les élus que vous êtes ils ont un rôle à
jouer
pour expliquer à nos concitoyens ce qui
se passe j'ai pas eu l'occasion de vous
tendre cette perche mais vous m'en
donnez l'occasion maintenant le
délestage une procédure réglementaire
donc elle est définie par l'état elle se
fait en discussion avec les préfets crt
eux qui prescrit des volumes d'énergie
qu'il faut faire baisser ces mis en
oeuvre par les réseaux de distribution
et de manière générale ses réparties sur
le territoire sur le territoire national
donc non il n'est pas prévu et ne sera
jamais prévu de couper
une région
à fort sur et monsieur molac la bretagne
j'y tiens elle est chère à mon coeur
très bien monsieur mollahs comme vous
aviez encore un peu de temps vous pouvez
rebondir si vous le souhaitez un
c'est bon c'est clair oui c'est clair
non on a déjà parlé beaucoup
effectivement delà des économies
d'énergie et je pense que quand je vois
les collectivités locales par exemple
avec des consommations d'électricité la
nuit en lampadaire etc je pense qu'il ya
un effort à faire à ce niveau là est
depuis longtemps
très bien écouter on nous avons terminé
avec les orateurs de groupe chez
maintenant passer aux questions
individuelles sur ce principe je vois
qu'il ya des volontaires sur ce principe
c'est une minute g président top chrono
à une minute je coupe tout le monde et
vous prenez toutes les questions et à la
fin vous répondez librement à toutes ces
questions qui sont prises
individuellement tous que c'est une
phase d'écouté active vu le nombre de
questions et vu tout ce qui va vous est
posée je vous propose ce sont les
députés qui ont une minute et ensuite
vous vous répondrai à toutes
ensuite donc on joue un peu ce qu'on
sait par eric bothorel
merci monsieur le président mais c'est
le président du directoire à te j'ai
souvenir d'un échange avec le sgdsn qui
dit souvent en situation de crise la
première victime de la crise c'est le
rap pas le document de gestion de crise
donc j'entends que vous nous dites le
scénario du pire n'arrivera pas je le
souhaite nous faisons plus que croiser
les doigts et nous allons compter sur
les élus pour relayer la parole
effectivement d effort de sobriété
nécessaire pour autant je vous poserai
la même question que j'ai posée à madame
la ministre n est pas en espagne la
chaire hier et qui devrait compléter
celle de paul molac sur le niveau de
granularité ou de maillage chinois et
finesse d'exercice des opérations de
délestage si jamais elle devait arriver
pouvez-vous nous garantir que si en
ultime recours nous étions amenés à
faire du délestage nous préserverons
quand même un certain nombre d'outils je
pense notamment aux stations radio
communication qui assure les
communications samuël police gendarmerie
étant entendu que la nécessité de
couverture mobile mais d'être préservée
merci monsieur martinez
monsieur le président merci pour cet
exposé qui était en effet très très
clairs et instructif je vous remercie
notamment de cette démonstration
implacable est extrêmement critique
vis-à-vis du marché européen
l'électricité puisque vous nous avez
démontré à quel point ce marché à une
incapacité à fixer un prix qui soit
juste nous savions déjà que ce prix
était très éloignée de la réalité des
prix de production mais vous nous avez
aussi très bien démontré à quel point le
marché anticipe mal le risque de pénurie
vous avez évoqué le fait de d'anticiper
un doublement par rapport aux risques
réels il ya une autre façon de le dire
c'est que le marché spécule et que
certains grâce à ces hausses des prix
engendre des super profits donc la
conséquence de ça c'est que et vous le
savez peut-être notre groupe
parlementaire défend la sortie de ce
marché de l'électricité est la question
qui revient juste après c'est si nous
sortons de ce marché quels sont les
moyens qui permettront les
interconnexions et les échanges entre
pays européens puisque nous pouvons
échanger de l'électricité sans qu'elles
soient régulés par le marché et donc la
question à tressignaux pose donc
mouvements réalisés merci
monsieur potier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président
député du grand est je m'intéresse au
mix européen énergétique et à la façon
dont vont être valorisés des capacités
d'interconnexion européenne dans le
cadre des sécurités sous pour dire un
mot et puis un autre on est sur le temps
court les trois mois qui viennent noël
etc et puis rte nous avait impressionné
sur ces scénarii pour les futur
énergétique est ce que c'est de savoir
et cette pédagogie vous la mettez
toujours à disposition de l'assemblée
nationale des territoires pour animer
les débats qui arrive sur le nucléaire
les énergies renouvelables mix énergie
la sobriété et c'est ce serait on attend
un signal de votre part pour continuer à
vous mettre à disposition de ceux qui
veulent réfléchir et préparer l'avenir
merci
si beaucoup monsieur d'aubiac
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du directoire merci pour votre
exposé particulièrement claire et et
instructif sur les perspectives de cet
hiver c'est je crois c'est précieux pour
les députés que nous sommes
le pdg d'edf nous a précisé le contexte
effectivement autour de la disponibilité
sur le nucléaire on voit qu'un effet que
j'ai obturée l'ailier également
sur les difficultés de stockage
hydraulique et la production
d'hydroélectricité dans cette même
période ma question est aussi simple et
pour répondre aux préoccupations de nos
administrés c'est notamment dans une
perspective de l'hiver froid et de
coupures à réaliser pour des
particuliers quels sur les modalités de
mise en oeuvre de ces coupures et
notamment la prise en compte de
situations critiques particulières pour
des personnes qui pourraient être
hospitalisées à domicile avec 2
assistance respiratoire notamment
quelles sont les modalités prévues
peut-être les préfectures ou avec des
élus locaux pour pouvoir prévenir ces
personnes en situation très critique
merci beaucoup madame simonet
merci beaucoup pour votre pédagogie et
puis vos travaux montrent bien parmi vos
six scénarios qu'il est possible à
l'horizon 2050 d'envisager d'atteindre
100% d'énergies renouvelables est donc à
la fois de décarbonés et de sortir du
nucléaire je ne partage donc bien
évidemment aussi la nécessité de la
sobriété que ce soit pour le court terme
face aux risques de coupures ou que ce
soit pour le long terme pour réduire
notre empreinte carbone maintenant la
question c'est quel sobriété une
sobriété heureuse une sobriété subi une
sobriété ou bien rationnement puisque
comme vous le savez il y a déjà 12
millions de personnes en situation
précaire et énergétiques 5,2 millions de
passoires thermiques alors vous dites
d'abord mobilisons les entreprises la
convention citoyenne pour le climat a
fait une proposition klein simple la
suppression des publicités numériques ça
serait un bon départ je souhaiterais
aussi vous interroger sur la question de
l'impact de la généralisation du travail
du dimanche est ce que à un moment donné
revenir sur cette généralisation
en capacité de mesurer les conséquences
ce mation monsieur maisonnée
merci monsieur le président votre
modélisation rte 2050 vous avez refusé
d'établir un scénario qui maintenait la
part du nucléaire à 75 % de la
production totale d'électricité pour des
raisons qui nous échappent un petit peu
quoique et comme par hasard vous nous
avez présenté un scénario central qui
correspond peu ou prou au programme
macro nist or nous nous disposons d'un
nombre considérable de témoignages de
dirigeants de la filière nucléaire qui
eux nous assure pouvoir maintenir 75% si
et seulement si on leur ont leur donne
les moyens pour 30 ans donc je voudrais
savoir pourquoi mêmes même presque je
dirais de quel droit rte a enterré d'une
certaine façon un scénario d opposition
emmanuel macron merci
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur madame sabatini
je vais tenter de répondre à ses
résidents vous ne prévoyez au maximum
que 12 à 13 % de la part de l'industrie
dans le pib en 2050 une trajectoire est
incompatible avec la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique puisque les
importations compte pour plus de 50% de
notre empreinte carbone pourquoi ne pas
avoir établi un scénario à 20%
d'industrie ce taux est incomparable à
la part de l'industrie dans d'autres
pays européens où un frein dans les
années 90
bien je n'ai pas d'autres demandent si
pardon érigé jardins à lille eric merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président merci pour votre excellente
présentation votre rapport sur les
perspectives du système électrique pour
l'automne et l'hiver 2022 2023 et claire
et dans le pire des scénarios nous avait
dit rte envisage de réaliser un blackout
contrôle et en organisant des coupures
d'électricité de quel tel que vous
l'avez modélisés dans ce contexte je
souhaitais vous interroger pour savoir
quel sort était réservée aux productions
individuelles d'énergie type panneaux
solaires ou éoliens raccordés au réseau
pour des besoins de sécurisation et
d'injection de l'énergie en effet elles
ont besoin d'un minimum d'électricité
pour fonctionner sont elles entièrement
répertoriés seront elles concernées
les éventuelles coupures de courant je
vous remercie
madame bateau
merci merci monsieur le président oui je
vais me focaliser sur des questions
techniques considérant que
les autres enjeux relève effectivement
d'autres d'autres interlocuteurs merci
pour la présentation
les mesures de sobriété qui sont évoqués
qui sont des mesures d'urgence qui comme
ça a été dit auraient pu être anticipés
sont somme toute très modérée
dans celles qui sont décrites en détail
à partir de là de la page 55 du rapport
et là dans les travaux vous avez fait
ces focus sur l'hiver qui vient
immédiatement
est-ce que
c'est dans le prochain rapport
qu' on va pouvoir entrer dans une
trajectoire de réduction des
consommations
plus important je parle en termes de
chiffrage je vais prendre un exemple il
ya été évoqué par une collègue même si
on peut considérer que c'est un exemple
qui traduirait plus un changement
culturel qu'un impact en tant que tel
sur la consommation tout ce qui est
écrans numériques publicitaires etc là
les chiffrages qui sont faits sont sur
des modifications de créneaux de
de service alors que ce sont des
installations on pourrait se passer ma
deuxième question par d'anciens
présidents sur les entreprises madame
bateau sur la règle est la même pour
tous on fait une minute pour chacun
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
attendait là on va se réinscrire à la
wepad riches non j'ai
mal de bateaux vous découvrez pas les
règles aujourd'hui je vais appliquer
tout le monde jeudi une minute par
personne pour les questions
individuelles bon je veux bien qu'on
l'apprenne n'ya pas avoir fait une
minute en attendant que le micro comme
un autre je vous assure on l'a remis à
zéro le micro madame bateau mais c'est
pas grave est-ce que attendait juste est
ce que tout le monde a vu poser une
question bon vous voyez pas
d'inconvénient à ce que madame bateau on
pose une deuxième une minute près de
bateaux c'est alesi madame passé dans
les mesures sur les entreprises
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est très court
beaucoup d'entreprises évoque
pour réduire leur console le passage à
du télétravail est ce que rte a chiffré
en fait la comparaison entre tous les
salariés d'une entreprise ans chez eux
en train de chauffer leur domicile et
ainsi de suite versus le l'utilisation
des systèmes de l'entente fin je pense
que ma question est comprise
très bien tout le monde a pu poser sa
question c'est bon très bien monsieur le
président je vous laisse et répondre à
la totale pas de contrainte horaire
particulier si ce n'est quatre visiteurs
n'auront bruno le maire que je voulais
se dérouler
alors j'ai commencé par les questions
qui ont porté sur futur énergétique 2050
et nous allons y répondre à deux voix
avec thomas vers un coup nous avaient
interpellé monsieur maisonnais sur le
plafond de nucléaire qu'on aurait
artificiellement cissé à 50% madame
s'abattit sur la part de l'industrie
manufacturière dans le pib à 2
de 12 à 13% est donc dans ces deux cas
la réponse est la même nous n'étudions
que des scénarios qui sont réalistes
nous l'étudions des scénarios que doux
qui sont un réaliste je m'explique
dans nos séries au futur énergétique
on prévoit au maximum 14 tranche de par2
d'ici 2050 on est d'accord pour dire que
le jalon de la neutralité carbone c'est
d'une cinquante c'est pas 2060 et donc
effectivement thomas
va nous rendre compte de de la
concertation qui a conduit à ce qu en
écoutant les professionnels et les
filières industrielles nous ayons fixé
un certain nombre de limites industriel
parce que la france ne peut pas se
transformer d'un coup de baguette
magique thomas je t'en prie sur le sur
l'industrie manufacturière et sur le
nucléaire
mais la concertation
je pense n'avoir frustrer personne dans
l'industrie nucléaire parce qu'aucun
acteur industriel ne m'a proposé un
scénario qui pourrait maintenir la part
actuelle du nucléaire dans un système
qui est croissants en électricité
puisqu'en fait en 2050 les centrales les
plus anciennes auront aurait soixante
dix ans que l'hypothèse de référence que
nous avions prise en accord avec tout le
monde au début de cette concertation
c'étaient qu'elle ne pourrait prolonger
au delà de 60 ans et qu'à la fin de la
concertation en accord avec nous on a on
a dit que dans un scénario on pourra en
projet certaine au delà de 60 sous des
conditions très précises qui pourraient
être fixées par l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire donc en fait
vraiment par rapport à la proposition
initiale qui nous a été présenté dans
cette concertation qui était de six
réacteurs nucléaires construits à partir
de 2035 1 une paire tous les cinq ans
qui convient quand même à une part du
nucléaire qui va vers 25 % on est quand
même très loin de 75 on a quand même
envisager des scénarios il y en avait
plus voire beaucoup plus jusqu'à un
scénario sobriété n 03 où la part du
nucléaire est de 60 % en 2050 donc
vraiment par rapport à ça je peux vous
assurer que nul n'a été frustré parmi
des acteurs industriels de la filière
nucléaire qui nous ont qui ont participé
à cette concertation
merci alors si vous le permettez on va
je vais tenter de répondre à l'issue de
celle là sur les nos perspectives de
long terme sur la question du marché
européen je crois c'est une question qui
a été posée par nos cieux martinet il
faut faire une différence sur la
critique qu'on peut porter au niveau de
prix et sur le fait qu'il faille qu'il
existe un marché en europe ou pas le
marché européen aujourd'hui il a le
défaut de dents dans la manière dont les
prix sont fixés en france de surestimer
le risque et le but de notre travail
c'est de remettre le risque à son niveau
de manière objective donc que les prix
baissent en revanche le marché européen
il a une grande fonction c'est qui sert
de dispatching d'électricité il permet
aux européens de se répartir
naturellement de l'électricité moi je
veux bien qu'on se dispense de cette
fonction du marché européen qui est le
grand dispatcheur d'électricité je veux
bien qu'on pose l'hypothèse mais
simplement il faut qu'on se demande
ensuite qui demain va être l'autorité
qui à chaque heure à chaque heure du
jour et de la nuit va décider des flux
entre les pays et ça c'est une très
bonne question et c'est une très bonne
question non mais c'est une monsieur le
député c'est une très bonne question
politique c'est pas une question qui
oppose au président d'un opérateur
public c'est une bonne question
politique à se demander qui est
l'autorité publique qui à chaque heure
du jour et de la nuit
déciderait que la france exporte peu
importe de l'électricité vers
l'allemagne ouvert le le benelux à titre
personnel je n'ai pas trouvé mieux que
la fonction de dispatching européen cas
sur les marchés
ça ne m'empêche pas ça ne nous empêche
pas donc avec thomas verhaeghe de
critiquer la manière dont les prix sont
formés pendant la crise c'est d'ailleurs
ce que nous avons fait devant vous mais
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse jeter le
principe du marché et la solidarité
qu'il permet tous les jours et toutes
les heures entre les pays je ne crois
pas qu'il faille y jeter cette plus
value de solidarité
avec la question de la formation des
prix qui je le partage avec vous pose un
problème très important en france et en
europe en ce moment donc je fais la
différence ce entre les deux je regarde
un aspect et jeux à critique l'autre
nous avons alors vous avez des questions
sur le délestage de la part de monsieur
bothorel et de la part de monsieur
taupiac
là ne croyait pas que j'essaye de fuir
mes responsabilités mais en fait ce
n'est pas rte qui est responsable de
l'organisation des délestages en france
c'est je vous ai dit c'était une
procédure réglementaire donc nous
appliquons le droit c'est vrai que c'est
rtl qui décide s'il doit y avoir des les
stages ou pas parce que c'est nous qui
sommes responsables de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
et en fait ce délestage il est mis en
jeu il est mise en oeuvre de manière
opérationnelle par la distribution
si je devais faire court c'est rtl qui
constate la veille au soir vers 18h30
que la consommation va pas passer et que
à moins qu est qu as tu es rouge et les
effets très profond nous allons être
contraints de délester donc certes qui
donne un truc l'instruction à la
distribution sur une trentaine de poche
de consommation en france les agences de
conduite régionale de la distribution
par agence on leur demande de baisser la
puissance de 8 heures à 10 heures de 10h
à 12h et de 18h à 20h
en infra de cela c'est qu'à la
distribution
d'organiser les soupes auch qui sont
coupées avec des règles qui sont fixées
par arrêté les clients sont classés en
cinq catégories
il existe des clients prioritaires qui
sont dans des poches qui du coup ne
peuvent pas être coupés et donc
l'ensemble de ses sous poche elles sont
classées de 1 à 5
et c'est l'ordre des échelons de
délestage donc on peu délestée l'échelon
1 à 3 à l'échelon 4 et 5 qui contient
des clients prioritaires lui ne peut pas
être délesté si vous souhaitez avoir des
détails sur la procédure de délestage
autant il est vrai que rte donne l'ordre
de délestage parce que nous sommes
responsables de l' équilibre offre
demande autant je ne peux pas être aussi
précis que je l'étais sur le reste de
mon exposé sur la procédure de détails
parce qu'elle n'est pas dans mes mains
elle est dans les mains de la 10
missions et des pressions
voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur le
délestage
alors je vais répondre à à delphine
batho madame la ministre vous nous avez
dit que nos mesures sur la sobriété
était modérée dans ce qu'on a écrit sur
le passage du verre je suis d'accord je
suis d'accord et là aussi on a été
prudent on a juste montré qu'en prenant
avec une mobilisation collective d'ici
début de l'hiver et en prenant des les
hypothèses qu'on a prise d'ores et déjà
on était capable de passer l'essentiel
des situations même dans des hivers très
froids
la seule conclusion qu'on peut se tirer
de ça c'est que c'est plutôt bon si
c'est qu'on peut on peut gérer des
hivers et les pique un peu un peu
compliqué je partage avec vous que la
société française pourrait être plus
sobre
et alors c'est des choses qu'on va
interroger dans le futur étude on va pas
refaire futur énergétique 2050 je les
dis les fondamentaux ne sont pas remis
en cause à l'échelle 2040 2050 où il ya
des choses qui chance plutôt à échéance
2025 2030 2035 et ce sera l'objet de
notre publication
du printemps puisque au printemps on a
prévu d'écrire un un bilan prévisionnel
à cette échéance avec mise à jour y
compris des des contraintes
macroéconomiques sains que génère le
contexte et le désordre mondiale qui
influe sur la manière dont on est
capable de faire des travaux sur
l'ensemble du monde de l'électricité de
l'énergie de manière générale
monsieur le président je regarde
j'essaye de répondre à toutes les
questions alors sur le télétravail donc
on a de la ministre bateau a posé une
excellente question c'est très difficile
à dire en fait
et qui a été relayée par madame simonet
sur est-ce qu'on serait capable de
chiffrer l'impact sur la consommation de
plus de travail le dimanche ou moins
parce que c'était moi
ce deal merci à perdre huit chalets ont
fait des analyses sur le passage de
l'hiver donc on essaye de comprendre la
variété de choses
non c'est très difficile honnêtement on
n'est pas capable de faire ça à ce degré
en tout cas ce contrôle de thomas vers
un de ses c'est très difficile sur le
télétravail moi j'ai répondu à une
question ce matin là dessus
déjà si d'aventuré la question du
télétravail se posait parce qu'il y
avait des risques de coupure sur le
système électrique encore une fois je
vous redis nous pouvons les élites et si
on se mobilise pas mais si d'aventuré le
système et les traits tendus la question
de toute façon se poseraient et là c'est
assez difficile à dire parce qu'on n'a
pas beaucoup de références il ya eu du
télétravail pendant le coc vide mais
au tout début du coc vide au moment du
grand confinement les particuliers ont
consommé plus mais la production
industrielle s'est effondrée donc la
consommation d'électricité s'est
effondré mais on n'a pas envie que la
france s'arrête la france dont je vous
parle qui qui relaie la sobriété et qui
relaie le 6 à l'éco hâte c'est une
france qui marchent normalement c'est
pas la france qui tombe c'est une france
qui travaille c'est une france qui se
déplacent c'est une france qui n'annule
pas de train c'est juste une france qui
est raisonnable qui est solidaire et qui
fait attention au chauffage à la lumière
à la cuisson et à tout ce qu'ils
consomment de l'électricité de manière
inutile on n'est pas du tout dans un
monde de la france alors vers même dans
un système électrique très tendu voilà
long du coc vite c'était un nom d'allah
est donc effectivement il ya une chute
de la consommation je crois que c'était
moins 15% de sur uniquement les
consommations des industriels ce qui a
été absolument redoutable donc c'est
très difficile à dire moi ce que j'ai ce
que je dit juste c'est que
si on s'imagine que le télétravail
va pouvoir résoudre la question alors il
faut qu'on assume jusqu'au bout et que
ce jour là on chauffe pas les bureaux et
qu'on les éclairs pas
parce que rien ne serait pire que de
proposer aux français de rester chez eux
et pardon de parler de vie quotidienne
mais de lézat de les inciter à se faire
un petit frichti de midi parce qu'ils
sont chez eux et a soutiré sur leurs
fours leur plaque de cuisson et a monté
un peu le show face parce que parce
qu'ils sont chez eux pendant que les
transports en commun fonctionnent
normalement et pendant que les bureaux
qui devrait les accueillir sont chauffés
sont éclairés et que le restaurant à des
entreprises lui aussi a lancé ses fours
pour faire cuire des plats au cas où le
salarié viendrait bon et on est un peu
dans ce monde là et c'est un peu
alternatif donc prudents en tout cas
nous ben mami ce qu'on n'a pas vraiment
de donner pour faire une une
recommandation là dessus c'est vrai que
les postes de consommation dont on parle
me pousse à être un peu prudent sur les
effets d'un appel au télétravail si
d'aventuré on était on était tendue en
tout cas il faudrait que ce soit donc
accompagné de mesures d'ordre public qui
serait pas formant pas forcément très
agréable si je peux juste de rebondir
mais il existe très peu d'organisation
vous pouvez faire du 100% télétravail et
en entreprise ou en fait vous avez une
partie de l'effectif qui en télétravail
est une autre qui vient quand même au
bureau et j'imagine mal à avoir du sens
pour centrer travail du coup c'est à
dire que le scénario du pire que vous
pas le scénario du pire le cas de figure
où en gros on demande aux gens d'aller
oui je après moi moi moi moi du coup je
j'abonde dans cette question là et je je
je je la complète moi la question je me
pose c'est est ce que vraiment le
télétravail est une mesure d'efficacité
énergétique si vous avez quand même
l'obligation de chauffer le bureau pour
user quand même quelques salariés qui
viennent au bureau et vous avez pas les
laisser dans le froid
en même temps les autres qui sont à la
maison et qui vont chauffer qui vont
consommer midi etc qui vont du coup et
les transports qui marche quand même
discrétion nous hisser la question c'est
est ce qu'on ait des études sur ce sujet
pour le nom des qualifiés en tout cas
donc à ma connaissance non et donc du
coup est ce qu'on appelle le risque
d'avoir beaucoup d'organisations qui
sont pas en mesure de mettre en place du
100 % télétravail pour éteindre
totalement le chauffage au bureau est un
en bureau éteindre les ordinateurs
biotteau que cela pose la question de ce
sera jamais binaire oui les autres pays
font comment ce sujet alors un je ne
sais pas d'accord ce sera jamais binaire
on peut tout à fait concevoir par
exemple dans le siège de de rte à la
défense on serait capable de fermer des
étages et ne pas échauffer bon
moi je sais pas j'ai pas de données
précises là dessus c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est très compliqué je
préfère demander pour passer l'hiver des
engagements aux entreprises de baisser
leur console au faget l'électricité gros
postes de consommation et aussi à des
entreprises qui nous disent que les
jours ecowatt rouge bah en fait le
restaurant interentreprises il va
consommer moins d'électricité au moment
le pire c'est-à-dire de 8 heures à 13
heures et donc ils vont faire des menus
qui sont adaptés alors donc une fois de
plus c'est pas la france qui tombe ce
n'est pas la france qui s'arrête c'est
ce sera pas que salade pour tout le
monde mais il ya des entreprises qui
s'engagent déjà à ça et moi je trouve
que c'est c'est une bonne démarche d'y
penser voilà et à l'instar de ce que
disait delphine batho je crois que ça
nous fait cette crise nous permet de
nous poser les bonnes questions
et de nous et de demander vraiment ce
qu'on est capable de faire en matière de
sobriété donc la manière dont ces
impacts
notre vie quotidienne
alors je rassure dominique potier sur le
fait que nous sommes toujours à la
disposition des élus pour discuter de
futur énergétique 2050 il s'avère que le
moment où on présente le passage de
l'hiver je ne vous cache pas monsieur
députés qui nous rend pas très
disponible mais dès qu'on aura passé
cette vague là on est à votre entière
disposition pourrait discuter mix
énergétique long terme
je j'ai l'impression que alors j'ai pas
répondu sur l'hydraulique
j'ai pas répondu à madame simonet alors
dans la suite de la réponse ça madame a
misé delphine batho quelle souris
étaient au rationnement on est d'accord
que nous on est pas on n'est pas dans un
monde de rationnement parce qu'on évoque
la sobriété qui sont des mesures
générales et puis donc ecowatt qui sont
des mesures volontaires donc on n'est
pas dans le rationnement derrière le
rationnement et à l'idée d'un d'un
impératif de consommer moins 1
donc donc on n'est pas dans cette
logique là
on n'est pas capable d'ailleurs
techniquement de priver les français
d'une partie de l'électricité qui
veulent consommer soit il consomme soit
en les coupant fait
donc la question du rationnement on
n'est pas capable de prévoir un demi
début d'eau pour vous imposer des
puissances maximales à consommer en tout
cas ce serait compliqué je suis pas sûr
que vous serez ravi qu'on vous
l'imposent c'est la raison pour laquelle
on parle de solidarité et d'engagement
voilà et ça me semble pédagogiquement
plutôt une bonne manière de rentrer
aussi sur les questions de sobriété qui
sont aussi notre avenir là cette fois ci
pour des questions de souveraineté et de
et de neutralité carbone puisque ça ça
permet de renvoyer la question sur bah
en fait quelle énergie on consomme
laquelle s d'où elle vient et à ce
qu'elle posait problème de pollution et
de climats d'à côté est ce que parce
qu'elle pose des problèmes de
souveraineté de l'autre et donc à titre
personnel je trouve que c'est un bon
exercice que de se poser cette question
de la sobriété
g il me reste la question de monsieur
girardin que j'avoue ne pas avoir
totalement comprise
sur la question des panneaux
photovoltaïques voulais préciser mme
gerda en deux secondes
ont des besoins sécu pardon excusez moi
merci sécurisation et d'injection
d'énergie est ce que ces énergies là qui
sont finalement complémentaires elles
subiront pas les coupures d'énergie
éventuel les coupures d'électricité
éventuel pour les alimenter c'est plus
clair mais ce président
à daisy navale c'est pas grave en fait
ouais prendre part à
votre question porte sur de
l'autoconsommation sur la production la
production solaire
oh oui il faudrait absolument il faut il
faut qu' il n'y a pas il y aurait pas de
raison me semble-t-il que un panneau
solaire ne puisse pas fonctionner
indépendamment du sud du système mais
bon je pense que ça nécessite peut-être
qu'on qu'on se voie après pour voir ce
que vous avez en tête précisément en
tout cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que de deux manières de manière générale
bien évidemment
pour cet hiver et pour les hivers
suivants tout ce qui permet de
développer la production solaire comme
la production éolienne comme tout type
de production de toute façon nous aide à
améliorer notre niveau de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et nous permet
d'économiser du gaz donc de toutes
façons ça vaut le coup
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires j'adore nous avons
répondu de la manière la plus exhaustive
possible à l'ensemble de vos questions
et donc nous en avons terminé je vous
remercie de votre attention bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le président je tenais
vraiment à vous remercier pour votre
présence pour le fait d'être venu aussi
vite après votre conférence de presse
preuve en est aussi que vous respectez
la représentation nationale et que vous
venez immédiatement après l'avoir
présenté pour répondre à toutes nos
questions on a pu vous interrogez à fond
je trouve que l'exercice est intéressant
parce que vous avez posé les scénarios
les options de façon extrêmement
transparents
didactiques pédagogiques et que ça nous
a permis d'avoir un débat sur sur ses
solutions là et puis merci aussi pour
cet esprit positif et optimiste sur
notre capacité collective si nous
réussirons à
à faire ces économies d'énergie à passer
le cap évitez les scénarios les moins
heureux et à se dire qu'on peut y
arriver collectivement en tant qu' en
tant que nation merci encore monsieur le
président je vous propose chers
collègues d'une suspension et nous
reprenons à 17h pour bruno le maire
merci